there will be more battles
Char must
prepare get the season pass to unlock an
exclusive mission to destroy the
Guardians of the Flaming eye and battle
sauron's Elite Legions to earn epic
runes
test your skills in Four challenge modes
gain experience in runes and compare
your victories with friends on the
online leaderboards season pass owners
unlock every challenge mode instantly
for a head start in their domination of
Mordor time to go
hunting gain new skills and unique epic
runs as you hunt and tame legendary
monsters of moror in these all new story
missions my Powers return play as Kell
bmore the great Elvin King of the second
age and wield a ring of power to face
the dark lord siron
himself I like
it